uh
just
thank you fellow councillors
invest media in public
clear this meeting of the
tuesday the 26th of july
2022
at the
council
chamber
to remain upstanding for the council of
prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment
as we face the tasks before us
and enable us now
and always worthily to discharge
the sacred trust truth
placed by the people in our hands i mean
i mean
uh
okay
apologies
use any apologies
declaration of interest
are there any changes there that
counselors
and it's an amazing how to
at the 28th of june
the
discussion there
oh second
moved and seconded
further discussion
put it to the boat all in favor say
when it's an infrastructural services
committee
meeting held on the 1st of
july um i'll move that those uh minutes
are turning true and correct
and be received
second education
moved and seconded
a new discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against
minutes of the performance
policy and partnership
committee meeting held on the 20th 12th
of july
i'll move those minutes be received your
worship second that
moved and seconded a new discussion
question
put it to the vote all in favor say hi
hi
again
and now a rather lengthy report
on
the means treble
um i've got an
interest in this
if it helps your worship could i suggest
that this item be the last item on
today's agenda
so that his worship can work through the
other issues and then come to the issue
of the travel cost of the very last item
saves vacating the position and coming
back
there's any objections to that
put it to the bottom
say hi
hi
okay
so we may be next to the last item on
the agenda
um
good afternoon everybody i think of your
worship for you uh this is a correcting
uh report uh
the impounding act 1955
is of a legislative age that it hasn't
been modernized uh in quite some time
and unfortunately it still requires
council to set the fees for any stock
and
poultry that we may need to impound from
time to time
unfortunately that was missed during the
fees and charges round so this paper
simply brings the impending fees through
to this council to correct
and with that brief introduction happy
to answer any questions you worship in
the interests of making sure that chooks
are properly impounded i'm happy to move
the two recommendations and i'm happy to
second them your worship
just around the operation of of this and
michael sorry to dump this one on you
but
with the dog fees i know that uh south
and district council pay a percentage of
the
of the operation of that facility
um with them pounding do they
pay
considering that a lot of
of these impounded creatures
would seem to emanate more from outside
the boundaries rather than in
inside um are they do they contribute as
well too so um
thank you for your worship uh so this is
quite specific to
other creatures and we have a
surprisingly large amount of
uh creatures that get impounded within
the city
so this is separate
under the impounding act
a
pound keeper can designate any
place that they require um so a paddock
can be used in rural
um southland and southland district can
say that's a pound and they will be
charged
the pounding fee which is what this is
setting out
southland district do contribute to our
animal care facility
uh but that is in relation as well as i
am aware to dogs only right um it is not
true the word pound is just uh it just
happens to be
part of it it's some archaic legislation
not not insulting anybody of course born
before 1955.
very quick caveat on that thank you
right
thank you
thank you for that answer
carell okay
okay
thank you
michael
just in relation to the actual fees
themselves are they increased from where
we're at last year or the year before
um
that is a good question i can't answer
that uh councillor i think um trudy uh
hurst is here she should be able to
provide some clarity on that
um
don't appear to have a microphone
no um
but as i'm sure you can see from them
the uh
fees at ten dollars or five dollars
are relatively
negligible
uh through you your worship
uh my
recollection and i need to confirm this
because i haven't got the information
just at hand
is that they were a reasonably similar
we were maintaining the same
level
for
so it's
impounding of a first animal for sheep
goats pigs and poultry for example is 30
and each additional animal is five
dollars
so these are
fees that people can avoid
when they have the right fencing or the
right containment for stock
so they're not a fee that you get
charged unless the stock have to be
impounded
i can come back via email to confirm the
exact figures
for council no that that's fine by me
you know i just wonder whether we've
taken the opportunity when we're
upgrading this to upgrade the costs as
well but if you don't think there isn't
that's fine
thank you any further discussion
questions
aye
your worship rhiannon suta has written
this report and she is away sick
her manager who authorized the report is
also a way
i'm happy to answer any questions that
counsellors may have
well thank you worship um look my
question on the soi is around the um
the funding high and it shows
uh stakeholder funding
is 47 and external funding is 53
now just with the
space ops being removed and that would
have contributed
to the previous 53 percent
um i'm just wondering what the balance
is is it
is it still going to work out okay and
not require any more shareholder funding
with the space ops being removed
or how does that balance out your
worship the shareholders have made it
plain that there is no additional
funding so
great south have been advised that their
funding shortfall is a matter for them
to
manage
and that the shareholders will not be
bringing forth any additional money
okay just if that's the case then it
brings up a technicality because
um with the new space ops being a
separate cco
uh the actual accounting side of it
trans if it needs money out of space ops
then i don't think that is
that couldn't be done transparently you
you can't have great south suddenly
drawing on
cash out of space ops to fill that gap
so
you're just saying they just have to
sort it out full stop
your worship if counsellors remember at
the time
sorry at the time of the draft statement
of intent the message given by council
was in fact let me start that again the
message given by great south was
if you are unwilling or unable to
provide additional funding for us
we would suggest that we stop funding
these other or we stopped doing these
other activities council's decision was
we were unable unwilling to provide
additional funding and we prioritized
where we wanted to see them make cuts
that matter now sits with them to manage
their house accordingly
yeah that just wasn't that evident in
their statement of intent yeah that's
okay we'll wait and see thank you
okay further questions suggestion
answers
thank you your worship um just want to
make a comment on the
um page three of four reference to the
statement of intent process
and it's it's pointed out that the um
process has been that the mayoral forum
as a de facto group representing the
class a shareholders has been steering
the process for the last three years
um and that
there may be some thought of changing
that
to the joint shareholders committee
it doesn't exactly affect the
recommendations today but i suppose the
question would be
what the advantage of that would be
considering that the class a
shareholders do have
can i say more interest and reason why
the statement of intent is important
of importance to them as the class a
shareholders
i think i would like
to ask that
perhaps the reasoning behind widening
that to
the the joint shareholders committee as
a whole
in the future is brought back to us at
some stage i would like to know more
about the
the reasoning behind it and any
advantage to the scene and widening that
group beyond the class a shareholders
your worship i'm happy to address
councillor sopa's question now
the shareholders agreement states that
the
which is to be read
alongside the constitution and it states
that the monitoring and holding to
account function
for great sales activity should be
undertaken by the joint shareholders
committee as the issues of additional
funding came up over the last year
um
i think that all of us have become more
aware of the fact that there's been a
and
if i use colloquial language there's
been a muddying of the waters between
the role of the south and mayoral forum
and the role of the joint shareholders
committee
the
desire behind the establishment of great
south and the joint shareholders was to
recognise the role that the ilt and the
ilt foundation and the
community trust and others have in the
success of the regional economic
development agency
and the joint shareholders committee has
not been meeting as often as it should
this
um
and your right counselor it's not a
recommendation but this reference to it
in the report
is really seeking to bring back clarity
to whose role it is to ask is great
south doing what we think it should be
doing is it performing well in its role
and is it doing what we want to see it
do through the statement of intent
process and that's why we're saying we
should push it back to the joint
shareholders committee
as part of the
living to the intent of the shareholders
agreement
you for the um
for that well thought out response i i
think i would i would still probably
like it of course to come back to
council before that changes
is made
and i think all the class a shareholders
probably want to discuss it before it
becomes a
i think what's become evident is that
the class a shareholders
need to meet and discuss
the
performance and funding requirements
and stated aims and objectives of great
south and make sure that everyone is
comfortable with those
i think that the matter of spaceops has
highlighted that the communication
between us has not been as good as it
should be
and you may recall that we are
undertaking a review of the constitution
so making sure that we've got the right
mechanism for shareholders also can be
sit alongside that
thank you that gives me more comfort on
the on the issue
thank you
i think you wish i've got several issues
um on page um
page 34 of board books there's a list of
shareholders a and b and i just wanted
to clarify because i understood that
mona fenway had a role in one of those
clusters of shareholders has that
changed
your worship there is no reference to
evie in the constitution
and i i mean that respectfully that
they're not
shareholders
recognized in the constitution
separately
um on page 45
of our board books going forward
uh there's a statement financial
position and i guess one of the things
that unhinges me a little bit is that
earlier on this year we had a
presentation by um great south that said
that they were running a bit short of
money
you'll recall about half a million
dollars short because some of their
government contracts were relapsing
and yet i see there in the financial
statement they've got more than two
million dollars worth of cash and cash
reserves
um so i guess that's a bit of a signal i
appreciate the fact that you said we'd
be putting no more money into it as a
shareholders
but it does raise some concerns that
they've got some money sitting in the
bank
the other issue
sorry mr chair and i apologize for
interrupting
i just query what year that is
um
well it's going for it's the budget for
the parent company going forward to the
30th of june uh 2023 so that's the next
year
but the the information we got
some time ago what was about next
financial year not this year yeah
so they were signaling they may need
some more resources from us and we push
back on that i guess
your worship we have no additional
resources in our budget
to provide to great south
that's fine
the other issue is the issue of space
ops and i'm late to this um issue of
space off but there's some still some
issues of concern for me
i said at a meeting two meetings ago
where the a stakeholders clearly made a
decision to appoint two directors to
space shops
we didn't approve to the third director
which is peter heenan who i don't know
your worship could i just remind all
council that some matters have been
considered in public excluded previously
and there is no reason to maintain that
now but some matters may also remain
confidential and counsellors might like
to consider that in terms of just where
they're going to go with their questions
well
i'll back away from the names but
it worries me that as
a stakeholders
that we approve two directors to space
ops
and there seems to be a push by great
south now to have a third one
your worship i'm going to remind all
councillors that it's your decision
to indicate whether you are prepared to
see a third director appointed
and it's your decision whether you
endorse
any recommendations put forward by great
south i
i want to be
very explicit that this is the
governance role that you have over a
council-controlled organisation
now thank you your worship i think
if you look at the companies act
section 5 i think it is is
when you look at is is space offices a
subsidiary or a standalone cco now
if it's a subsidiary
in that sense of great south
then great south
according to to the companies act would
appoint the directors
and stuff if it is but if it's not a
subsidiary
and it's actually a cco then
it would be
the joint committee that would appoint
the directors your worship
i'm very mindful of taking up time
particularly when we've pushed to the
end of the agenda another item
and this is an issue that councillor
pottinger has raised on a number of
occasions
great south is a cco
it wholly owns another company
by law that is a cco
councillor pottinger has raised whether
that should have been consulted upon
and councillor podinger is correct it
should have
however it hasn't been
and what that means firstly is the
auditor will have a view about that that
will be reported on in our annual report
and secondly
it really means that we can't go back
and do that
because my advice to you would be
that to consult when the action has
already been taken
would be to make a mockery
of
our understanding of people's views
so much in all as we might not like
the outcome
we need to accept that spaceops is a cco
in any event greatsouth have also said
they are prepared to make uh
recommendations to council on directors
but council as one of four class a joint
shareholders
and as a member of the joint
shareholders committee will get the
opportunity to express its views there
and so
this council can take its views forward
to the joint shareholders committee and
that will have an impact on any further
directors at space ops
so in your worship can i just clarify at
what stage we will have the opportunity
to uh discuss the directors i sat at a
an a shareholders meeting which was the
four councils within the last two months
and we decided on how many councils
there would be
so are you suggesting that there will be
now another meeting
where those
those
considerations will be put to us for a
second time your worship there can be no
appointment
of an additional
or indeed an alternative director
without this council having considered
the matter
and then the joint share and every
council that is a class a shareholder
and then having a joint shareholders
committee
anything else is just ink on a page but
not actually a decision to be
implemented
and and counselor as somebody who was at
that meeting i think you can have
confidence that we will continue to
promote that line
when that was the position put forward
at the joint shareholders committee
meeting at the time
and just a final point your worship in
relation to space ops and i just want to
clear on a strong favor of of space ups
i think it's a great initiative
but the people surrounding space op
don't tell us [ __ ] as us a shareholders
a hell of a lot of information about
what's going on that's my view
and recently they said to us we will be
raising capital and i raised the issue
how can you raise capital when you might
be compromising
our council and our council's debt
profile and the chief executive raised
similar sorts of concerns as well and
the response was we will come to you
before we need to raise
capital and that's a concern
so
your worship i'm sorry if i've cut
councillor clark off but at that same
meeting there was an undertaken sort
that there would be no capital raising
until after
this council and every other shareholder
that wished to had undertaken a risk
workshop to ensure that spaceops
appetite for risk
met the shareholders appetite for risk
and it has been made particularly clear
to the chair of great south that any
debt raised would be part of our debt
profile and would be inappropriate until
that has happened
if councillor clark would like
he could add an additional
motion to the recommendations you have
in front of you
asking that this chief ex the chief
executive of this council
right to seek that undertaking in
writing again to make our position
particularly clear
you should worship that could be an
option uh one of the things that worries
me is i did ask the
ian colley who's
involved with both great south and with
space ops
like what sort of debt level would you
be raising and i said to him
specifically we're talking half a
million dollars a million five ten
hundred stop me where it is
and i didn't get an answer i just gotta
this is all commercially sensitive
you worship i have sympathy with
counselor clark's view
and all i can do and all we should all
do
is stick to the process
of what we can control at this point in
time what we can control at this point
in time is you shall not raise debt
until we have considered it because it
will be part of our debt profile and it
will be part of what the choices you are
able to make thereafter
your worship of counsellor clerk as of a
mine to move a recommendation seven
along the line suggested i am very happy
to second that recommendation
yeah i'm happy to do that your worship
but i guess there's a final reflection
um
we're putting an awful lot of faith in
in the process as the chief executive
explained
but as what uh council podge has already
raised we've had
faith in the system before
when the cco was set up
and we weren't well advised at that time
as well
so and the same players are still there
your worship we will get another
opportunity to look at this at the
beginning of the next
council
in terms of appointments to committees
such as joint shareholders and indeed
the joint shareholders determining who
their chair is
thank you
thank you worship look in the in the soi
from
great south that contains a sort of mini
soi from space ops
and that
clearly states the next
three years sort of business plan and
i'm totally aware of what counselor
clark is getting at and is worried about
but that three-year business plan
from space ops shows that
any dividend or any
commercial money made will be reinvested
into space ops again now
i would expect
the that
soi from spaceops to indicate
that they're not happy or they need to
expand in business as usual
is
is not what they're doing so
just standing just going from their
statement of intent
i just they they're not signaling any
expansion dramatic beyond beyond what
they can produce themselves
that require that would require further
investment from the shareholders so you
can read that in the uh statement of
intent there it's a wee section
showing showing that so i understand
where nobby's coming from
but if we can trust this statement of
intent they'll have to modify their
statement of intent to really
i think so um
maybe andrew cameron may know
whether that is uh something that a cco
would have to do before they could
launch out on grant grand schemes
uh excuse me asking andrew did you wish
to comment
he was hiding behind the pillar
probably on paper i was just preparing
the motion for
consideration
i think the short answer is that there
is some debt indicated in the forward
modeling
uh i think at this stage it's only 500
000 but
you're not it's not clear as to where
that debt is going but there is you have
a look on page um 46
uh there's borrowings at a group level
coming in in the 22-23 financial year so
other than that
the statement of intent doesn't indicate
any borrowings
just the final comment you worship so
i'll just leave it that i'm
uncomfortable
um
the sequence of events is that uh space
ops made about five hundred thousand
profit this year and reinvested so
that's fine that's what council of
potter's talking about
but since then they have talked about
raising capital
so i guess i'm just a little bit nervous
about that because that has some
liability for this council
i'll just leave that sitting there thank
you
there's a discussion
uh you worship there were six
recommendations on the report and
malavika has put in red the seventh
recommendation
that
i think councillor clarke wishes to move
yes i'm quite happy with that thank you
and i will second and just make the
comment that this is us exercising air
a class shareholding rights and i am
very much
in favor of that being done
and
your worship i probably should ask
councillor clark and councillor sopa
prepared to move and second the
recommendations one to six
thank you
i don't think there's any further
discussion you may like to put that
motion you worship
no further discussion i'll put it to the
right
[Music]
and there so now we will ship it is
[Music]
received this at the end of the meeting
um
i'd like to invite council
cheer to meet him
and i'll step down
any cash
um can i ask a question please your
worship
wouldn't you use your deputy to chair
the meeting when you're standing aside
yes peter i was asked to do that but
because i've been involved with the
decision decision-making around the
mayor's
travel arrangements that was felt that
somebody else neutral should should do
that
i don't want to be in a position where
we might have a split vote and have to
have a casting vote
so i think somebody has been neutral to
the debate that we've had in the last
week or so would be helpful
you're available
yes sir you've just checked this diary
thank you
your ruling or your thoughts on
my thoughts and i believe that
challenges for the mayoral position
coming up in the election
um could be tend to have a
conflict of interest
and
by referring to the perception of it and
just carry on i refer to the perception
that uh out there in the public arena it
could be
discussion of an election
and i just wanted a ruling on that
because
it suggests that uh people that are mere
candidates should perhaps refrain from
this debacles
sorry lindsey we're having buffering
issues with you but i think i've got the
gist of what you're saying
um
we're in a position
in the training where anybody actually
can still
yet declare
on this
issue i haven't expressed an opinion and
if anybody who's standing for either
mayoral candidacy or
intending on re-running for uh for
council is deemed to have an interest
then there's gonna be
not a lot of people with anything to say
so i don't see that it's a
an issue in this process
thank you for raising
counsellor
i just i just wanted to clip
good point of my thoughts
yep thanks lindsay appreciate it holy
crap
[Music]
we're losing you so i was on the graham
norton show for a second
thank you councillors um you may also or
may not be aware that in your email
there has been a response sent through
from sir tim
um
has everybody had a chance to to look at
that prior to the meeting it did arrive
very late
yes
yes it is i'm sorry counsellor i'm
actually going to ask that counsellor's
um
delete that and put it to one side
uh and just to explain the thought
process around that michael do you wish
to give advice
yeah it's um understanding what it is
it's a financial uh conflict of interest
for his worship
uh which means that he can't speak to it
or make any form of submission on it and
his email is unfortunately considered a
submission so understanding orders you
can't have any regard to what this
worship has said right okay thank you
for that i guess then there's a matter
of process what we were
looking at sorry
councillor um
uh councillor abbott was going to speak
he may be buffering still
um
if i let's see
if i can carry on for a moment that
would be really useful
thanks
um
so as a matter of process
we've got the report
um
and that the council consider matters
what we needed to advance the process is
an understanding
that costs were
reimbursement costs were going to be
sought um i i think the email from his
worship has alluded to that but
regardless i guess that can go straight
to the chief executive or or
through whichever process through which
reimbursement is sought but i guess it
does it does help give us a dollar
figure although mrs hadley you had a
um
counsellor i think the best
i think the best answer is if i say to
you that i am asking you whether you
approve costs of up to 500 dollars
okay uh lindsay sorry councillor abbott
okay now i understand uh we have to get
some clarity um i'm just making the
point that the amount of 525 dollars if
it's reimburse
amounts to and i'd like you to just note
this figure um point north north north
north north 45
of the annual operational expenditure of
115.9 million
so when i reflect on the numerous
overseas trips that many around this
table have had
the out of area conferences etc
different guises and then the 20 000
expended approximately only seven
delegates to attend this local
government
it's a poultry sub 525 and i just even
wonder why we're debating it um and i
just look to the fact that
you darren i think said publicly just
recently
that if you'd been able to attend that
meeting and um it was
suggested that perhaps you could have
councillor scout's budget and take some
money through that that was not me
that's never been a process it was
approved by council and it's been
discussed in two previous years it was
councilman that was councillor potinger
oh okay sorry i'm sorry about the name
we've got the name wrong and you should
remember because you offered me your
travel funds
yes indeed now i'm about to do the same
to the mayor if it's possible if he
wants to take my 525
and in my time on council i've never
expended any of the budget never been
anywhere so i welcome that but i'd still
say that it's a
it's a delicate situation 525 represents
nothing to what we spend on a meeting
daily basis and i would just like to see
the respect of the office of the mayor
and his rental costs met some way
thank you so for for not wanting to draw
attention to something that's a great
way to tip picture along councilor lush
councillor
thank you mr chair i was just going to
suggest that before anybody discusses
the matter any further perhaps we could
move that the report be received i'm
happy to move that way
it brings it on to at least brings it
onto the table uh look i think we can
deal with with
yes now you're right so you're moving
the report be received seconded by
councillor kit thank you put that all in
favor
against carried so now it's on to the
matter whether or not uh we want to meet
costs of up to five hundred dollars as
councillor abbott has already pointed
out it's it's not a great sum um
but
councillor clark you uh
yes i'd like to speak to this issue
because i was the one that sort of a
guest
uh instigated the
dispute back last weekend or the weekend
before so just a little bit of
background to this um last year at last
year's conference the mayor also sought
to have a rental car
provided and the primary use of that was
for his family to get around blenheim
and surrounding areas and the mayor was
required that was declined by council
and the mayor was required to reimburse
that cost through four nightly
installments
um we have a regular sensitivity report
that goes to risk and assurance
where we have to
comment on these sorts of things
and um
when i was initially approached about
three months ago about this
my initial view was that we wouldn't get
into a public spat over what was quite a
poultry amount according to lindsay
but at the time i didn't realize that
the mayor was flying into wellington as
opposed to parks and north like the
others and so the rental car would be
going significantly further than what
was i initially thought it would be and
that there were two additional days of
accommodation in there for his
requirement uh not for hours
and so the
mayor has been very
critical publicly about councillors who
are seeking his role with the next
election so that's a majority of the
chairs group that would normally
discuss these matters and it was also
critical in the email about the chief
and executive's involvement so given
that this issue was raised with me about
three days before he was actually
traveling i decided as deputy mayor i
should take a lead on this and not
engage with a whole lot of other people
that might get knocked around in the
media as well
so i got in some discussions backwards
and forwards with the mayor's partner
who had the authority to speak on his
behalf
um there seemed to me to be two sets of
costs that i didn't think that councils
should bear one was two nights
additional com
additional competent
accommodation in palestine north and the
rental car
other elected members were given the
opportunity to travel invercargill
christchurch palmerston north
so it's up wednesday back saturday
the mayor was also offered that back in
april this year
but declined
because he wanted to make arrangements
um
for to take his family and the travel
ranges he subsequently made went into
wellington because it was cheaper
um and he was factoring in that he could
ever have a rental car from wellington
as an attempt over the weekend to
mediate this so that we didn't end up
with this public spat i offered on
behalf of council to pay for the two
additional nights accommodation which i
didn't agree with but i did
offer to do that
i also suggested to his worship that he
should fund the rental car
because that's consistent with last
year's approach where we didn't approve
and thirdly and more importantly
i suggested to the mayor if he wished to
be reimbursed for the matter he should
bring it to his council meeting his
colleagues collectively could decide on
whether it was a small amount not to be
worried about or whether there was some
public perception about additional costs
of mayor that others were not incurring
and they should bring that here and then
the collectively we could all make a
decision so it's not just people who
might be aiming at being men next time
around i didn't get a response to those
offers what i got was a telephone call
from the odt and subsequently from the
new zealand herald and subsequently from
q a on tv one
which i think was very poor form because
i did try to resolve this
so my view is
we've paid 490 for two nights of
accommodation the rental car is about
the same amount and i think given last
year's decision it's appropriate
that the mayor incurs the extra cost
because the cost is primarily for his
family
not for him
if his family were not going he would
have flown in and out of parliament like
everybody else
thank you thank you councillor partner
um look
nobody's raised some
sorry councillor clark has raised some
uh some good points there but
uh if we go to
and that's why we have these policies
and in fact
if you look at the local government act
the leader of our policies is the mayor
um we have a sensitive expenditure
policy and it's got
quite clear chapters in here and anyone
can go online and see it on our website
about private travel extended travel
traveling with spouses and family etc
etc
so
generally the way this would work if you
played out our policy is that you would
benchmark what it would cost for
the one person
flying
say in the cargo christchurch
palmerston north the three nights
accommodation
the meals and taxis associated with that
and that sets a sum
and then you would
take what
the mayor has
accumulated with his modes of transport
and uh
you would seek uh
ram but well you would pay the extra
above that that is the personal cost
it's quite straightforward
and that decision is not made by council
in fact you submit those claims to the
chief executive
and that's what i thought the mayor
would have done is it's quite simple
and he would have kept a record of his
costs it's not it's not up to
a counsellor to have council pay for
stuff and council chase him for the
money it's the other way around it
always happens that way in business
the member would incur costs on his
own credit card and then claim it back
accordingly to these rules to me it's
straightforward
in the grand scheme of things
for the sake of 500
this is frustrating and and
personally i think it's the timing of it
is mischievous unhelpful and and a
distraction
but in order to try and progress things
i'm prepared to move the council and
prove the reimbursement of costs to the
mayor of up to 500
uh subject to provision of appropriate
receipts
it's on the table councillor arnold um
yeah i was just going to say like all
that all these points are very good but
there's one week thing that we would
definitely meant
sir
and to be honest
i doubt whether he'll be able to travel
to the lg nz
on his own unaccompanied so
i know that doesn't really sort of
change anything within the
within the rules that are written but
that's this effect of the matter
that's just my view
thank you
councillor kate then councillor partner
yeah thank you chairman
as far back as i can remember
we've always paid for
the mayor's and previous mayor's travel
costs
and
sometimes additional things
within reason
i go back to our previous mayor david
harrington and his
wife patricia
they not only got paid for conferences
but on other occasions when he had to
travel out of town
but i must say unfortunately i wasn't
here as i was in my sick bed when you
discussed the number of people you sent
a conference
i believe it was an overkill to send
eight people to conference
if you look at the south and district
council including their community boards
they have 69 people
elected and they only sent three people
the city council
including the bluff community board is a
total of 19 and you've sent eight
i have a question though
why did we have to pay or why did we pay
for a non-elected member to go to
conference
i'm referring to the manufinova rep this
is nothing personal
to me this is totally unacceptable
and should not have happened
and i believe it's ludicrous if you can
fork out three thousand to send one
person to
to the conference and you can't pay
a paltry five hundred dollars to meet
him
so
the answer to your question counselor
it was approved by the performance
policy and partnerships committee to
meet the costs for river and cook's
attendance
well i believe they were wrong but there
you go wasn't here you weren't
but it was carried by a majority so
understand the question
councillor partner um look with that
motion that's now on the table um we're
going to note that we're inconsistent
with our policy
or because we have our policies i just
want need to know that if
we're making exceptions to the
policy um and doing doing something
different do we need to note that
councillor clark and over and over that
where does that leave us with last
year's decision where we declined a very
similar amount
well that's why it's on the table and
open for discussion
sure
counselor cricket sorry
um
thank you mr cheer um
like you this is extremely frustrating
because the matter of five hundred
dollars and it um
it it's honestly the fact that this just
gets so much air time and so much media
for five hundred dollars just is
extremely frustrating but the fact of
the matter is that it shouldn't even
come up in the first place we have a
sensitive expenditure expenditure policy
which this council
unanimous unanimously ratified in 2018
because it was uncovered that there's
been a lot of really random and
interesting expenditure across the years
some spans 21 years of sir tim's
election as uh tenure
in 2016 it had found that he'd spent um
over eighteen thousand dollars at liquor
stores
uh nineteen thousand on books and
magazines showcasing himself personally
three thousand dollars on wristbands etc
that was those were directorate expenses
weren't they it's if you're talking
about the item that was published on the
taxpayers union
uh website those were directorate
expenses
it speaks to the mural fund that he's
saying is now being washed out into thin
air
um which is part of this that he used to
have the mural travel that was part of
the murals office and they had the
mayoral fund he's now saying it's gone
and these were those items that came out
of that fund
um
the fact that we have a sensitive
expenditure policy it's only five
dollars but five dollars every time for
21 years really adds up
it's
for me it comes down to
i'm not a mural candidate i'm not
seeking his seat but i do really hold
integrity and the fact that if i travel
for council i'm not going to incur any
additional costs to the company that is
not a business cost or to the to the
institution that isn't a business cost
my uber receipts um in attendance which
i was in attendance there this council's
council ratified because i'm on the
young elected members committee so i was
actually there for a purpose
facilitating learning and development
for young elected members not just
in attendance i was there for a purpose
um
i just i hold integrity in the fact that
we are there for that reason i know it's
only 500 but at 500 every time and this
isn't the only time the mere travels for
us across the year
it just
it's the principle
thank you councillor rabbit
yes sir thank you for that uh question
really to uh counselor clark
i have seen the emails that uh
corresponded between you and the mayor
and
the marius if you like
and
do you agree that there was a compromise
made from them but they would actually
pay for the extra nights the one in
wellington the one in palmerston north
and the extra days rental of the
of the um motor vehicle
did that happen
uh no that that's not correct what they
offered was to pay one of the extra
nights and one of the five days for the
rental
and that that to me was going too far i
counted that by saying
i'll pay for all the accommodation which
is
half the
cost roughly and you pay for the rental
car wasn't saying no to the rental car
just saying it shouldn't be my decision
because if you read those emails it's
clear that the mayor felt that i was
politicking at election time trying to
run him down i guess
and that was not my intent i offered up
this committee oh sorry this meeting so
that i would not be the sole decision
maker on it
i mean it's a sad indictment that i have
to make decisions on this anyway
i'm just asking whether the compromise
was that they would pay for knight's
accommodation and the day's rental of
the car yes they they offered one one of
the two nights and one of five day rent
one of the five days of the rental
and do you think that he will comply
with that
well that wasn't for him to comply
they offered that up as a settlement and
i said no to that
okay thank you
okay just a couple of small points the
difference between this year and last
year is that last year the flights went
straight into blenheim's there was no
need for a rental car
because of the timing
of when his worship made his bookings
the wellington option was the difference
the sensitive expenditure angle is
something that ends up being reported to
the next
risk and assurance committee
councillor sopa
thank you uh councillor um
[Music]
just for clarity's
sake do the reinvestment of costs up to
500
include only the rental vehicle or are
we talking about accommodation and
rental vehicle or are we talking about
the possible production of other
receipts
i i just think
um perhaps we have become slightly
confused what are we talking about i can
clarify that
um the the 523 is the rental car
the f 490 is the two nights
accommodation that's separate to the
rental car
so all up if you include two nights and
the rental car without the fuel you're
talking close to a hundred dollars oh
sorry a thousand dollars
so what the
disregarded email from the me referred
to was
looking for
um
[Music]
400 something dollars so that's why the
motion says
reimbursement of costs of up to 500 i
don't care what it is whether it's a
mixture of accommodation and the rental
vehicle of what it's it's the figure
that's what i wanted clarified thank you
any other questions or comments
councillor lewis thanks joe i'm just a
little bit
confused i think the extra cost of the
flight from from
wellington
north that's been taken into account
didn't fly from wellington to palmerston
everybody else flew direct into
palmerston north
sorry through the ring from invocable
it's not going to happen
so the actual two flights were involved
for the councillors going to the local
government's act
include costs obviously
the the difference between if the mayor
had
gone
with the rest of the councils on the
same day whatever what is that actual
difference
i couldn't say because it depends on
when you book and it's a dynamic booking
system as far as ticket prices go but
the earlier the better usually which is
why
shortly after registrations of interest
were called full back in april people
were encouraged
to have flights booked at that stage
sometimes the later you book the more
expensive it is but sometimes you can
get standby fares that are very cheap
[Music]
any other questions or comments
councillor clark just wanted to clarify
your last statement here so when you
suggest you know i think
lindsay also reinforced it that you'd
pay costs up to 500 are you talking
about 500 costs towards the rental car
or you're taking are you suggesting 500
costs all up
well the letter that we don't refer to
was just looking for costs around the
rental car
yep so
so what we've got in front of us i guess
now is that
um the mayor is happy for us to pay for
two nights accommodation 490. but that's
now seeking another 500. the mayor did
pay for one night's accommodation
privately okay
so council has paid for one the mayor
has paid for it thank you
so this request is for reimbursement
then essentially that just leaves the
rental vehicle yep
any other questions
if not i'm prepared to put it to a vote
all those in favor if you could raise
your hand please
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
eleven
does that work uh councillor clark has
not raised his hand
the mayor is not present in the marathon
reps can't vote at council thank you
declare the motion carried
uh there being no further items of
general business i'll move that we go
into public excluded and call back his
worship to chair i'll second that
thank you michael could you think all in
favor
against carried thanks to the members of
the public for attending the press and
for those who've joined us on the live
stream which
is ending now
you